tu vas nous faire celle avec lequel avec
le asus ravasi a raison elle un peu
l'eau gabès pas avant d'être là ils
veulent surtout pas nécessaire pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas un petit garçon
sa mère elle lui dit va acheter de la
confiture
parce qu'en fait cette pénurie de
confiture dans le quartier est l'une des
vaches et c'est épices et je suis sûr
qu'il en a il y va monsieur l'épicier
maman avait de la confiture dit ça tombe
bien j'ai la confiture qui vient des
états unis et il entend sonner comme un
fou tu vois il prend la confiture il y
va et sur le chemin et des confitures
des états unis bas mais goûter et à nu
alors ils ouvrent garde à gauche
personne leur garde et du professeur
rossi sa mère maman trouvé mardi mais
c'est quoi ce bruit d'un mois cette
confiture elle prend mais c'est pas
possible avant de le prêter dans salle
de bain il s'en dit mais c'est pas un
quart des békés
la confiture séquelles familles de
malades vallée noire est facile et s'est
dit c'est pas sur les pistes
c'est d'avoir vendu confitures les pc
disent contents allez vous plaindre au
cou mais ça lui c'est pas moi le
commissaire du 3 mai excusez moi le
commissariat s'il vous plaît le tuf m
[Rires]
pour le coup je veux pas dans ses allées
bègles et bègue du corps
faux
[Applaudissements]
ces deux mecs ils ont grandi ensemble
ils sont des grands ensembles maintenant
les deux choix le primaire ensemble que
les gens semblent ici ensemble mais
arrivée à la fac chacun fait sa vie
trois ans après se raconte dans la rue
le premier duo bernard coco tu m'as pris
ben je vais très bien jo
mais si tu bbb bbb bbb bbb crise n'est
pas finie ça c'est l'ancien taux et des
mémés camp de jour tu vas pas là c'est
la pub là c'est quelqu'un que coco
raconté castaldi fait aider d'un coup
j'ai été voir un marabout du mama mama
[Rires]
docteur quant à lui dit non j'ai été
voir un marabout tu veux m'adresser du
bébé j'en peux plus de ddd de rides
écoute voilà la grèce et dubé et je je
je l'appelle le moment ma maman je suis
à l'appeler tweak est forfait jj en taxi
10 mai prouvent à pied le taxi le temps
qu'ils découvrent l'adresse nouvelles
d'eux il est d'accord alors le mec il y
va il sonne il est beaucoup bambins ont
dit oui nous savons pourquoi vous êtes
larmes entrés ils entrent ils dans une
pièce noire et il entend juste une voix
qui lui d'y entrer dans la deuxième
pièce de deux ans je ne peux pas pas un
problème si longtemps en enlever vos
habits
[Musique]
sa salade même et merguez il a aidé à
enlever vos affaires si vous voulez
parler d'erreur il enlève ses affaires
il se met tout nu et des poches et vous
en avant ça sent peu papa pas bon ça
alors il se penche quand même à l'avancé
pour beaucoup espèrent en avant qui est
un mec qui les met un concombre dans le
et au moment où libé le concombre ici a
dit revenez demain pour la lettre b
[Applaudissements]
il va nous faire d'auge et va nous
entendre
je la connais je rigole c'est superbe et
mâconnais tennis exceptionnel marange à
tort mais je fais c'est à toi merci à
tous parce que c'est vrai que de penser
à ce genre d'émission c'est pas tout le
monde aurait dit nous est en fait ce qui
marche dans cette émission
s'ils voulaient vraiment c'est comme là
on est une bande charrie même des fois
pendant l'émission c'est ça c'est les
blagues à son et alterne les raconter
quand même un cas la loi zir de deux de
rire de ce qu'on peut plus rire
aujourd'hui il ya des vannes qui vont
loin oui pareil notation et là tu es
content parce que tu es chez toi d'y
raconter ça largement rappelle demain je
la sens raf aussi l'auteur dernière qui
devient à ce que tu dois faire
il y aura la blague de bouder de 21h à
hollywood eribon ça m'est arrivé c'est
que ça vienne à aimer écouter deux
heures on adresse derrière ton et d'un
démon bouder ben goïta jack est ce qu'il
est difficile et mon cas c'est beau car
maintenant lui aussi la des black cats a
dit le prêtre qui cherche la poste c'est
un poste que c'est un post simple
un prêtre qui arrive au village chan
tournée avec mon spectacle j'ai d'autres
dans la bouche après deux quarts il dans
un village maintenant il connaît pas le
village tu connais pas bien
il cherche la poste tous les mecs à qui
demande la poste personnes le calcul la
commune est prête je pense qu'elle va
pouvoir pas dû parler mais un mec qui
complètement boury la pda le père est à
prévoir dès qu'ils se cherchent et ben
écoutez je cherche la poste eh ben c'est
simple la poste tu voi che droite sur la
gauche sur la droite
j'ai un poste est là le prêt qui s'y
faisait krutov à droite à gauche il
trouve la poste il fait ses affaires en
sortant d'un poster dit le seul mec qui
m'a aidé c'est un mec bourré alors je
vais aller prêcher la bonne parole parce
que ça veut dire il a une bonne âme
serait alors il va le voir et le bread
aaa alors vous avez une belle poussée un
peu
vous avez trouvé la poste mon père et
des oui j'ai trouvé la poste tu es
tellement gentil c'est une belle âme que
je voudrais te montrer le chemin de dieu
le tennis c'est même pas un poste
[Applaudissements]
abroger bravo bon bout des doigts